you know you get a gravitational wave
you know it's a gravitational wave but
it's a series of Wiggles what does that
mean it's not giving you an image of the
source so we need solutions to the
Einstein equations for various possible
sources black hole collisions that tell
us what those Wiggles look like and so
we can identify what's going on so
that's that's one thing we need
solutions to the field equation and the
field equations by the way I have just
magically appeared behind right so and
look how simple they are well that's
actually part of the question that I
wanted to explore I mean it it looks
simple but we physicists have this way
of hiding complexity behind the symbol
size of you and and for this part
actually I just want to take us through
because sometimes in these programs you
know it is meant for the general person
who just has an interest but we'd like
to sometimes do a little bit of the math
and if you don't like math you can shut
this part off but let's just do a little
tag-team here so this is the form of the
Einstein equations and if you're doing
it a little bit more precisely there's a
few more symbols in it if you're not
using the natural units that allow us to
set certain terms to one but even that
if we go a little bit further is hiding
this so this is actually a more complete
way of expressing the equations if we're
now going to unpack the meaning of that
first symbol G minou but then you look
at that and you say well wait what do
all those individual symbols mean this
is called the scalar curvature and that
thing G is called the metric and there's
this little combination of them that
gives you the scalar curvature but wait
what does that really mean well that's
hiding this complexity right here
because we have this way of hiding the
summation symbols within what we call
the Einstein convention using indices
that contract in a particular way so
that's what that symbol means
and if you go a little bit further and
ask yourself what is the first term arm
you knew that's the Ricci tensor and
it's given by this combination of stuff
but what's that new guy on the right
hand side that's the Riemann curvature
tensor what is that equal to well that's
equal to this combination where those
gammas are known as the christoffel
symbols
and then you take those and what are
they equal to we're they're equal to a
particular combination of the metric
contract with various derivatives of it
it's all just to tell you that this is
kind of complicated and the goal of the
Einstein field equations what all of
this in some sense is about is
understanding that guy called G which is
the metric tensor and it just tells
quickly what that is and I'll have a
little visual that will take us through
that as well right so so Einstein's
theories assume theory about space and
time and space-time is a geometric
structure and the metric tensor in some
says that every point in space-time it's
a generalization of the Pythagorean
theorem to actually you have not seen
this before you but you were following
exactly what I'd hoped you say so so you
said the Pythagorean theorem so why
don't we just put that app here for the
heck of it right now so you got two
points there and take us through what
you're seeing right here right so you
want to know the distance between two
points so now in general activity it's
not the distance between two points in
space it's the distance between two what
we call events in space and time and so
two what the metric does for
Pythagoras's theorem we know it's Delta
x squared plus Delta Y squared plus
Delta Z squared I'm trying to click and
kind of click on stay up with you here
we are there it is all right so there
that little formula there encodes the
geometry of Euclidean space now you can
also write it in terms of a metric and
it's a relatively simple straightforward
metric and what people in really long
before Einsteins time when they start
looking at general geometries of curved
surfaces they receive all how do we
describe if we now have a surface that's
got a complicated curvature we want to
generalize what Pythagoras did this
metric is there a convenient
mathematical way of doing it and here's
one just example just so people who are
following the math can go along here's a
curved shape if you will and the
distance between the two points is no
longer just Delta x squared plus Delta Y
squared square root which is what we
learned in junior
school but rather is given by some
unusually looking strange combination of
Delta x squared and Delta Y squared and
if you curve it a little bit differently
we learned that the distance between
those two points might be given by this
particular combination of Delta x
squared and Delta Y squared and finally
just to get to what you're describing in
the general case we can have
combinations that aren't even just Delta
X squared Delta Y squared we can have
cross terms like on the far right Delta
X Delta Y and finally to get to that
object called G the metric tensor this
is sort of a generalized version of the
Pythagorean theorem where you're going
to allow the surface to be curved and
that G thing there encodes the geometry
that Franz is referring to an Einstein
gives us equation those complicated
equations that we saw before where you
can determine the shape of space-time if
you understand the distribution of mass
and energy yeah yeah exactly right it is
nothing